there are ten types of people in the
world those who understand binary and
those who don't
okay there's really work when it's said
but written down the joke kind of holds
because if I do a one and then a zero
that looks like the number ten because
you expect it to be a normal base ten
number however if this is embroidery
then this is our units column that's our
twos column and so this actually equals
two in base ten and so you expect it to
be ten but it's not it's two and that's
the joke there are actually two types of
people those who knew this was binary
and those who didn't there are ten types
of people in the world those who
understand binary those who don't and
those who didn't expect this joke to be
in base three okay no good point because
I can guess you okay so it depends on
the base so if you've got one zero but
this time it's in base three then now
you've got a units column and then a
threes column and then nines and so on
and so that in normal would numbers will
be three and base ten and so the same
one in zero in a different base mean
three hence the three categories there
are ten types of people in the world
those who understand binary those who
don't and though you can generalize it
to any base okay it if one zero in base
B is going to equal V in base ten okay
so just I mean you can do there's an
infinite set of these jokes color up
there are ten types of people in the
world those who understand hexadecimal
and F the rest okay I give it to you
that one is actually quite funny because
now in hexadecimal which is base 16 one
zero in base 16 still does mean there
are 16 types of people and so there's
the one category of people who
understand a hexadecimal base 16
but then the remaining 15 in hexadecimal
15 is just the letter F and so when they
say F the rest they're saying 15 are the
rest or I guess the joke is the double
meaning where if you just say F in a
sentence it means you're implying fools
you're saying they're very foolish all
the people who don't understand
hexadecimal
why do mathematicians confuse Halloween
and Christmas
because up 31 equals Dec 25
okay so the joke here is that acht 31
equals
Dec 25 and the surface reading is that
this stands for October and this stands
for December but it doesn't opt can
stand for the eighth thing because
October is the eighth month in them it
was until julius caesar messed with it
and dec used to be the tenth month blah
blah
so anyway instead of using these as
months you can use acht to mean base
eight so instead of 31 being in our
normal base 10 setup if we put it into
base eight you have a units column you
have an eighth column and so you've now
got one unit and three eighths and three
eighths is 24 plus a single unit equals
25 and so three one in base eight equals
to five in base 10 which is y one equals
the other and y a mathematician would
confuse them
this video was supported by audible.com
and if you'd like to download one of
their hundred thousand titles for free
go to audible.com slash numberphile
I actually sampled the product myself in
the last few weeks I downloaded a couple
of mountaineering books while I was
holidaying in Nepal I love books about
mountains these are the two I chose they
were both excellent and it was actually
really good fun to be walking through
the mountains while listening to the
book having it sort of inside my head so
I recommend those two as possible ones
when you download your free one that's
audible.com slash numberphile and thanks
to them for supporting our videos